this video is brought to you by expressvpn
and Shopify people more on them after the
reaction it's fine I'm fine everything's fine
[Music] okay I've got it are you ready yeah
Pur did it feel like that took forever cuz
it's the forever Purge I'm still here but
you get what the pun that I made yeah forever
I could have been there I mean I could have
watched a whole movie from that to help the pun
but I just figured they might want me here what
voice are we doing today we don't know we
don't know it's my normal this is my normal
voice you know what we also don't know what's
going on with this movie do we have a purge
daddy we don't know we just know it's the
forever Purge that is the final movie of
the franchise at least so far all right Terra
what purging this time oh God she always asked
me that and I'm never prepared um we are
going to purge while you're thinking about
what to purge you guys at home don't forget
to like comment subscribe and ring the bell
ring the bell exactly we want to know
what you guys have thought about this
purge franchise so far I'm pretty into it I
love doing these movies with the Roxy it's
fun I love these it's Betty and Veronica it's
I always Snow White and the two girls in the
carala which girls are in the car felma and
Louise Selma and Louise well it's Teran Roxy Baby
yeah we're doing it yeah we're back we're doing it
live actually it's not live it's very edited and
that's a very good thing for us at the beginning
because oh my god do I make these extremely
long did you figure out what you're purging
no uh spiders I don't like them if somebody
steps on a spider or purchas spiders in this
movie then we're officially the happiest people
ever thank you so much speaking of the editing to
prepper for helping us edit these videos if you
guys are the sexiest of super sexy people then
you are already a patron if you are not you are
missing out please go over there so you can sync
up with your own copy Greg and John cover several
shows over there exclusively with highlights and
watch alongs included P got it one not a fortress
time but I am a Fortress are you ready yeah I'm
ready if there's no perch daddy I'm
going be very upset going to be yeah
I don't think Frank Grill's in
this but we might have another
Purge Daddy I hope so or maybe it's a
purge mommy oo I will look forward to
both vast landscape no one to
purge us here desert exterior
daytime anytime we see places like this in the
middle of nowhere it's just like how did this
get there do you have running water electri like
how ises this exist and why are there multiple
people there like they're all just but no
cars around y'all just been walking for a
minute oh they come this way they tunnel folks
love it I've never done any tunneling I don't
know that I should want to do that but maybe
it would be an experience I think most people
try to avoid living in the tunnels yeah skip
it yeah skip totally I don't think bucketless
material okay so something about the
Cel she's the mom of that
kid why did he run off like that I don't know
please don't start with a dead kid yeah oh
what I do recognize her but maybe she looks like
Kristen Ritter's sister yeah these colors don't
run is that what that said yeah on the on the wall
the what's that American bird the eagle yeah the
eagle American Eagle hey that's one thing I got
right you get a lot right [Laughter] babe [Music]
maybe it's not her son maybe it's just I
know when she saying me yeah but I agree
maybe it's just like uh son son but not illegal
immigration On The Rise Mexicans Fleet cartel
violence seeking the American dream one must ask
is the dream still alive no this a really cool
title sequence yeah the new founding fathers
immediately reinstate The Purge is the P the
the perch does stay true to itself trying to make
you think about where we live and what time we're
in I feel yeah like this title sequence makes it
feel like this could be our tomorrow right while
it's like this dystopian time it's also us yeah
is once again right Upon Us America divided by
y y h see I know this song Look at Her Go not all
the words honestly but [Music] text forever Street
text forever why does your brother have to prove
himself all the time keep call I got you I got you
will will I um will uh you might be is that his
name but also this more horse than you expected
huh she's something too I know someone who can
calm that Beast okay big actors yet again [Music]
yeah listen his shirt has Pearl snaps
so I know he's going to do [Music]
it he's jealous I know I can't think of his
name either I feel like it want to say his
name is Luke but I don't think that's
right I think I'm thinking Luke there
it is oh no that was cool no but horses
aren't supposed to lie down like that
right is it like cows where they can't get
up or is this how they sleep no he they can
get up okay yeah yeah yeah let's get back to
work he is the true Horse Whisperer make out
make out mhm yeah he knows how to whisper
horses and cook what a couple you need to
practice your English the talker family
would really appreciate that I feel like
he has perfect English yeah you know and have a
sister also an anny you should meet her we don't
need to meet her sister we're fine what's
happening to his side the horse it's really
hard to find good health and Anna's sister's a
sweetheart we don't need to meet Anna's sister
Emily what's up with the sister thing I don't
even know if I want our kids speaking Spanish
in this house oh got it well he's got to go
first but he won't so racism so yes I assume
even though she's that's probably her sister
right MH who would have thought I would be in
Texas I would succumb and go to the gun store
Kirk tells me that you're late this morning I
they were late sir hey Kirk ju here says you're
lying ju free man say whatever he wants no why
don't you show up late again I'm going to have
to fire you he's never late why is he such a
jerk TT your Purge protection bonus thank you Mr
Tucker stay safe so this guy Billy's good dude I
feel like he's nice right yeah he sees what's
going on Dylan believes a cowboy shouldn't be
from Mexico I don't know either I always taught
my son to be proud American and maybe I didn't
really teach him what that meant America I don't
even know if I know what that mean anymore proud
American mhm good point let's go dialogue damn
Purge protection bonus stay safe I feel like his
son's going to come for him in the purge yeah
that money's nothing but a way for these people
to Keep Us Alive so they can continue using
our slave labor for nothing more than that I
know what I'm going to use my money for though and
it's not for protection booze you need protection
for that talking about condoms yeah I mhm lock
those doors set those security systems and stay
inside for the next 12 hours and for those of
you who are partaking make God be with you all
why is that their is that their logo for this I
feel like somebody graffiti that a lot of these
shots that rotate like that are making me super
Buzzy yeah I think that's the point though they
want us nauseous so that they can Fortress Yeah we
see that America's reached a boiling point hatred
like that can't be contained you will burn your
cities to the ground it's just not how TVs turn
off anymore I'm going to lock down now y'all
also they do have lock down stuff out in the
country too that was crazy that we kind of see his
face as they were locking down like yeah oh wow
for the barn too good don't you mess with those
animals or I'll lose it as I've said why do you
care more about the horses than the people I just
can't handle an animal being hurt I can't do it do
you eat meat I do but I don't just checking
in I don't have to uh you know kill it yeah
o creeper some of the purge masks are so
creative yeah why are masks in general so
inherently creepy scary is it because you don't
know what's under it or is it because what the
actual mask looks like both but mainly cuz the
mass throws like off I think it just like throws
off your senses of like that doesn't look normal
like a normal face so it's like I mean obviously
it doesn't look normal I'm trying to explain
the psychology behind it but the words aren't
coming Captain Happ when the job's done know
you're good for it TT all right hey are you
clear on what they're doing are they going
to like a safe house I I don't know because
he just said get one of the jobs done so okay
make yourself at home okay so yeah it looks
like it's just like a okay but then the guards
this is funny business dude why is the guard a
white male starting y'all this is your emergency
broadcast system announcing the commencement of
the annual Purge sanctioned by the US government
okay so this is before this is okay before Purge
election then yeah cuz they're right unless
they went back after Purge election to doing
let government officials be off the yeah at 7
a.m. when The Purge concludes blessed be our
new founding fathers I like that they do this
for every movie though because if you've never
seen a Purge movie you could still hop right
in DN the rules that's true [Music] yeah and
this is all completely different characters this
could be the first and only Purge movie you've
ever seen yeah true you might be a little confused
on the premise yeah and right now I haven't seen
any blue flowers so we're not getting like the
world around yeah or you have to assum Texas and
this might be me being incorrect but you would
have to assume Texas would be Pro Purge right
yeah he's so crazy I what was that noise
and what is wrong with his side he's hurt
yeah they're in the pipes ooh he miss
spooky he missed it yes sir look check your
cam this is jumpy for
sure
funny how like guys like him used to play
the protagonist leading man and now in modern
movies if you look like him just immediately
I think that you're the villain which is just
right is what it is with his little combed hair
uhhuh cuz he's like the lead in so many romcoms
until now and then you see this and you're just
like you know this is an [__] he's a bad guy
yeah H to weon Fortress I knew
it those long with bullets that's what gets him
off bab okay Put the gun down why did she go
outside are I would have flipped out at him if I
was her he pointing a gun at my pregnant self The
Purge they to dictate how we live our life this
is our country and we can choose to bring a baby
into a world of love why are you laughing at me
so they're not pro Purge oh all right uh oh they
really just threw us into that real quick what did
we just witness a bunch of unhoused people getting
shot in the street yeah need some a it's my first
birge is what you expected well there's parts of
Mexico that sound like this every night we got
a nice spot here quiet I feel like an American
wrote that line got a nice spot here qu [Music]
Qui three Bogies inbound do not try to hide she
just picked up a weapon girl get it where's the
other guy who's supposed to be whose weapon did
she pick up this it was lying there will no longer
tolerate foreigners and paging the United States
of America yes that is what they came here
to do America will be American again see yeah
I shot don't you'll start a war and put
all your people in Jeopardy he will no
longer tolerate foreigners and paging the United
States of America people homies just be making
[__] up all the time yeah oh God absolutely
and justifying really bad things with their
lives they leave their own country they have to
flee their own country to come here to and right
yeah that's why that's exactly you know they risk
their lives to get here to do that [Music] does
that mean it's already over the last I think this
was this oh yeah yeah I didn't know if they were
doing a weird time thing where this was to start
oh maybe they faked it maybe they sounded those
alarms for fake well but it's light outside
though or their lights on no there's no way
that like somebody would have been like wait it
doesn't feel like come maybe they come to hurt
them anyway regardless of The Purge yeah ending
you know maybe they don't follow the rules of The
Purge maybe we do a time Jump to next year yeah
maybe this is Uncharted Territory we have never
done this in a Purge movie we haven't we're
very confused you told us what the format of
every Purge movie was is that we're just doing the
night of the purge now all of a sudden we're not
doing that we're 30 minutes in all right end of
act one after the P you be a holiday this holiday
holay oh no oh no what's gonna happen are they
going to get going to get hit I don't know that's
what it feels like oh God is a coyote or wolf
looks like a wolf it's so [Music] big this is
kind of interesting actually we've never seen
the aftermath and it is the forever Purge so
maybe The Purge just never stops right The Purge
is over and now the cleanup has begun all over
the state violence incidents ended hours ago is
whoa okay yeah I think you called it this doesn't
end so this must be post the election one
this must be the most recent in terms of
after the election one they decided to
go back to Banning hurting those people
CU otherwise we would have heard about The
Purge continuing right yeah oh no people are
hiding in there yeah there's that one
weird we saw two we just saw two okay
is a goat
yeah if you saw a goat in a cage on the
street would you I would try to just let
it out right without it getting run over I
don't know I would think it was somebody's
goat yeah I you know what I mean yeah I
wouldn't let it out I would think it was
somebody oh boy you are outnumbered
that is a lot of okay is it all his
Cowboys good question he said I know what
I'm doing with the money yeah buying a sick
mask to come take over oh no I don't
know about that babe I'm scared like
is it going to explode or something yeah
or like crush the like slice down on her
head I don't want te style oh I knew it yeah
what in the actual a oh waa that's an insane
trap this is giving me saw Vibes right now all
right I get it go watch your saw real rejects
reactions this bunny is freaky she said help me to
them you think they're going to help you Bab yeah
I'm like look at them terrifying Purge is over
this is the forever Purge it's never stopping huh
the oh my God oh my
God oh yes hot Pur daddy save the day maybe
we saw him earlier walking with her they work
together I believe you're all going to die no I
think you're going to die bunny boy yeah but is
he allowed to hurt them right now well like what
are the rules around right well I mean boss okay
yeah shite oh no didn't get them all
get it girl come on now oh no no no
yeah go darus go oh taste your own medicine
on your need attack we didn't do anything
the perge is over lady what the hell are you
doing we didn't do anything wrong listen to
me listen to us sir she's like [__] where's
everyone oh no oh is it going to be like the
the guy hates them but they're going to say
have to save him they're probably going to
be the ones that end up saving him I don't
know there the one dude oh No this must be
the cowboy right cowboy yeah oh that's the
crazy Cowboy yeah yeah yeah this feels like
Christmas any of y'all give me a present
I spent your money well but didn't he say
it won't be on protection these rich mother
can't hide behind their steel walls no more
this the way things are now boys this purge is
forever it would be a cool Halloween costume
yeah run towards oh you got to be a special kind
of you'll have to pay oh how much would you give
for her Dylan I forgot you're me now what you
me you have no money that's talk done without
money you can't save your own little sister
okay so now the guy that he hates is going to
have to save him and then maybe he saves that
guy's wife and then the world goes round yeah
got say I really like the makeup artist on this
so yeah like his eyes look popped yeah you're
talking about life in America the way to Rich get
rich off the backs of the poor the way it's been
ever since we robbed this land from the Native
America but you got no right to complain about
the very system your support by picking up that
gun and sanctioning the goddamn turd [__] this
is all about one of the things I'm thinking
is might he die right now because he's the
most famous one in the movie and they couldn't
get him to shoot the whole thing or will he's
well he went out with a pretty good monologue
I guess from my family to you go yourself yeah
you might be right about that shot him yeah wow
I was right you were right and he went out with
that whole monologue yeah for a reason I guess
I really knew that you did called it I'm like
okay we're halfway through that means that they
probably say they shot this for a month they
were they he was like I will give you a week
yeah and then I got to get out [Music] they
coming Forever After perch okay come on that's a
pretty shot I shouldn't even be here I did nothing
wrong there's no such got to love a swastica on
somebody's face it's real side do you think he's
on I know where she is this is the first real
purge don't do drugs kids stay off the shrooms
when you're puron it's just so hard when I
don't know if he's a good guy or a bad guy
with the swasa on his face like I just can't tell
so I don't know the a whole car of good guys yeah
maybe if they just reveal a different tattoo
yes yes [__] it's blocked hold on well good
thing you're in a semi you know what's tough is
that like we don't like him I know and I'm like
but his dad say movie where he's going to like
realize that those are his like true brothers and
they helped him and he needs to stop disc change
but there's no way he lives no way yeah he's going
to have to sacrifice you go get your wife we'll
stay here and protect the truck you don't need to
wait for us yes we do I'm coming with you what
no you don't have to do that yeah I do I saved
Our Lives and I know her from is it once upon
a time yeah you could be on to something there
but that is a 30 odd six word bro listen to that
Rhythm that is unck double bell shotgun Homegrown
Music from the Heartland right there oh God she
seems like she's at a festival yeah yeah like
EDM oh yeah this one's been missing the music
that some of the other ones have really yeah until
now
whoa that'll do it are we
in slow motion I think so
move a slow motion for oo that sounded like a neck
cracking oh oh boy I have to take care of this guy
what okay honey I would just start driving but did
you take this yeah but now his sister's there
I know it's tough I think that's why story-wise
they had her go in because otherwise they would
leave wish they would have set her up having a
little bit more of a relationship with the guys
who did save their life but that they'd been
around forever and she yeah to I don't believe
then I would have believe she would have gotten
out right he's about to get caught on the feet I
think cuz we're staying up up up [Music] up like I
was like what do you do he just like hung the horn
that's the only choice right that got me that got
me o all right good shot [Music] there yeah
like wouldn't he have known that that guy
had gotten out of the car with a gun and was
slowly walking around a lot of the people in
this universe don't seem too smart yeah
but also I think they're just like so
fed up with the society that they're
living in they just lost their minds
yeah I was wondering like why everybody
was adhering to The Purge rules you know
criminals she's got to open the door and help
right I know she's pregnant but open the door and
shoot him yeah oh I guess you don't have just
roll down the window yeah all right he's got
it I'm not trying to tell her how to feel but
I think she should look a little [Laughter]
happier oh oh this is not a
good position to be [Music]
in did you kiss her like that's
what you're thinking about right
now but we we didn't how could we have
known he was a bad die right we had no
clues she's not had the easiest time in
America no she really hasn't kick him in
the yeah yeah yeah I was like his legs
are just right in between him come on
now wa yes love a good just I wouldn't know
how to do that crack in the neck open it up
oh I kind of thought that might happen I should
have said it out loud cuz now you don't believe
me oh nice shot but before you shoot you got to
look yeah right cuz it could have just your sister
almost died not your sister your sister-in-law
get in the TRU get in come on I need to get in
my family help you I move faster than my own I'll
be fine no dead here you Sav my life thank you
Dar okay where is his family I we don't know I
don't think we've even met him so he's like I
I just don't know that that was the smartest
move on his part but maybe I would have been
like yo drop me off in my family you guys Dro me
off like unless his family is right there which
maybe they were and we missed that a world
is on fire with passion and love and actual
Flames okay so so far you were purging spiders
that hasn't happened quite yet yeah know I'm
sure there's been some of the foreground we
missed let's grab everything we can peanut
butter oh they're in love that's why she wanted to
help cuz she likes cuz they bone no they they're
in love already they bone already we think yeah
for sure for sure I'm scared to have my baby in
this world should be we're in this together it's
interesting choice to go up to her and say that
to her like she is your therapist yeah got news
what is it Mexican president Leon Garcia Solair
and Canadian Prime Minister Sophie pues are
opening their borders for the next 6 hours oh
so now they have to flee to their country very
interesting all right okay Mexican and Canadian
presidents doing what nobody in the entire world
is currently doing for the countries right we got
to go to Mexico it's going to be so interesting
for this mother yeah cuz I'm like oh he's going
to have to learn Spanish real quick we will be
ending our broadcast here good luck America stay
safe I'm like but what happens when they get
there is it just going to be peaceful and there
has to be like a purge there too or a place for
them to go realistically opening their borders
in Mexico and Canada like what would that even
do wouldn't the violence just Co I don't know
just move there right they but I do like the
premise of this being like now you guys need
to go you know it's a good it's a good advice
for the movie but realistically it's like what
yeah you look like Mexican what are you talking
about one Let's uh what do you say this uh slice
the [__] cut the [__] cut the [__] yeah
but he speaks perfect English it's so weird
that they're doing this yeah I got no problem
with Mexicans but I will say I don't understand
your culture just like you don't understand mine
I don't think white people any better worse than
anybody else we should all just stick with our
own just leave each other alone I don't know if
I've ever heard that take from anybody like what
is the movie trying to state is his opinion that
he actually is racist but he doesn't think he's
racist yeah I guess cuz it still is like stick
with your own and and I'm like yeah you're you're
making it seem like but he's the one s stayed and
waited for him after saying stick with your
own yeah and that's not what his dad believed
obviously it's just an interesting I'm always
in The Purge movies they are making political
statements they're making Society statements
and what was that statement they just were
trying to make it's weird cuz it's so different
from his like we don't need to meet your sister
that's that was like strong right well I guess
that's also stick with your own yeah that's
true stop this truck now stay down everyone
stay down what is that what is she looking
at of us that was easy yeah I was like will they
really you go Harper see you can't stick
with your own cuz they're in love right
it is also interesting we'll keep our
borders open for 6 hours right and then
they close it like what is if you're
in the middle of the country what plan
man whoa all right that's an intense
shot I can't even this is such a woo woo
comment but I can't even believe we have
borders yeah right like it's yeah some
where you're born I know people in the
comments are going to lose it over that sorry
it's just wild wild concept that we created
them just keep driving we got less than 3
hours please don't break down come on baby
oh God she's going to have her she's going to
be like my water broke like what do you do if
you're pregnant and that does yeah I feel like
that's going to happen she's broke down come
on we got to get out just a few blocks from
here we can make it everybody you follow on
they ready stay oh so now they have to get
out all right why follow on did one offer
that go go oh God just run man
oh okay was easy you slip this
is fil much darker yeah I'd also
be collecting the weapons on the
way she in a situation like this where there's
such utter chaos you don't even know who you're
shooting at like she just keeps shooting and it's
like could be a good person could be a bad person
totally like how do you keep the borders open
too and then this is what's happening yeah and
there was like a bunch of people just running
where you're like I've also never been to the
Border in Texas obviously I have many times in
California I'm kind of confused on the layout
of this like are are they currently trying to walk
across the border yeah I think they're just trying
to cross theater but like is the border that way
that way like which way are we trying to go well
I think we're try to oh Mexico Arrow right now
now I know yeah good signage I think that's why
it's all lit up with those cars except yeah yeah
the the cars are trying to keep them from going
yeah damn wait did that just blow up the
theater that they went in that was shot a
little confusingly I'm not quite I agree I don't
think we're supposed to know exactly what's going
on okay attention this area is under martial
law okay so it is kind of what I was saying
like once the US goes in for like martial law
and anyone who hasn't crossed the border what
are they going to do is just zap them up like
it's a little confusing no I think the martial
law they're saying you can't keep people from
Crossing yeah okay I think they're here there
to try to help people get across the government
doesn't want people to not get across right yeah
it's the people raging against the government
yeah a real bad what who did that that's like
a weird prop wait wait here okay at least she
knows how to hold a weapon in a flashlight I
enjoy that the women aren't like remember how
do I time you said yeah yeah I did it wrong
I did it wrong that's creative let's get out of
here you don't think they're real people I mean
that guy I thought he was alive I thought
I saw him move ooh get it oh good behind
you nice girl yeah reload [__] yes get it
Queen she said there are some Mexican cities
that sound like this all night long oh members
of Road roses in the beginning follow the with
the card Mexicans leave signs all over a city
to help each other is following them if we want
to find our wives we should do the same thing
smart yeah how come you know how to fight like
that I was part of the auto defenses a group
of women fighting the cartels we did damage
to them they first me and Juan off her this is
how we got here wow yeah well we remember we
know with her kid with the yeah I like that she
had to explain it her kid but the son yeah yeah
with the cartel situation they were talking
about yeah yeah I think you're right the US
government it was the radio people who said you
can leave but the government wants them to stay
move I you hand them over down drop your weapon
what is this nothing you can do drop them you
two Amigo the wives need to come right now that a
boy but who are you guys exactly is this Marshall
L just I don't think so they'd be uniform right
yeah look what we got here couple of bad ombres
what do you want to do about them daddy why don't
we give our fellow Americans here an opportunity
to redeem themselves you kill thees and the
two of you can live that's some saw [__]
help us purify this nation once and for all
that's what the ever after Purge is all about
they're going to say yes but then they're
going to turn and shoot them love it mother
gladly oh no and she loves him dang it
that's her lover yeah he's the one that
found the peanut butter to her jelly yeah
this is the NFA lay down your weap you will
be shot back up back up back up Dam it
you're just yelling back up coming baby
oh they have backup too all right I can't
believe they killed that guy I'm very upset
yeah it's sucks the green heue of this
oh oh nice got rid of her oh my God oh my
God
sounds like he keeps calling her mother he
is like she called him daddy daddy I know
but I Daddy's like kind of normal mother like
like he's not calling her mommy he's calling
her mother probably cuz they're incest babies
I'm sorry yeah for minute of Life they will
be here are you sure that this is safe cool
let's rage yeah I think it's time for a drink
yeah this looks like an
Elk Lodge we're on the same
team stop okay all right this is nk's Lodge
I guarantee if we looked up location they'd
be like they shot in a Elk's Lodge you okay
oh no she knows he's he's gone she knows the
El Paso border point will no longer be open to
United States citizens fleeing the forever Purge
Americans Left Behind the's border wall are being
slaughtered by purgers oh God now they're going
to have to sneak across the border for the first
time in in their American lives get out of the
back find CH Mo fast tell him to meet us in the
corner of Aman Island tell him if he doesn't do
this many people will die I like her she works
a lot I don't know her name obviously she her
voice is awesome yeah follow me I know a way
for safety you just stand up and walk you do
[Music] that it's like the government
did this to their own country by by
doing The Purge the thing that you and I both
thought was a good idea at first I know right
know so far now I've decided we
have a purge Mommy and it's her
yeah she is Purge mommy yeah take us to
Mexico please get him on board believe
him oh they have to shove in that in the
back of that van I was wondering if he was
going to come back full circle yeah imagine
crossing the border that way parts of the
train those b d holes can't build the wall
on too dangerous we used to makeig passage
we'll take you through some of you deserve
another chance some of you deserve another
chance that mean like I don't know what that
means cuz he's secretly going to try to kill
like the white people once they get there
Cassie we got to get you to Mexico I know
it's bad timing baby you'll be okay it'll
be help when we get across C's help you TI
up that's not the girl from Lost is it Claire
Emily R A something no I don't think so no I don't
think so what are they okay yeah looks like we
got trouble coming beat your mother what is [__]
ichim ichim MRE oh it's this guy the Vengeance
guy ironically the other dude is a mother [Music]
Bingo she going to shoot them or what I don't
they're getting closed we need to move yeah
she's I love you I'll be right behind you don't
leave me stop the baby I'll protect you get her
to the medics in Mexico put your under oh
interesting what is that I guess it's like
a motorized pulley a pulley system that's cool
we have a few guns but when the bullets run dry
draw them in close use blades it's not your
fight we've been fighting this fight for 500
years what does he mean it's not your fight
the point is we need each other yeah wait for
it I mean they got to see them I hope that they
surprise them but these guys got to
see them coming right nice okay cool
shot awesome those that's an interesting weapon no
it's cool to do a movie that it's
not a white savior movie you know
yeah I mean Persian mom's taking care of more
than the rest of them I think but even like
you know before it was like Frank gillow totally
yes I agree although at the end of that one um
like stamfield and all them coming through that
wasn't they yeah that's their butts too see I
guarantee you she still got ammo cuz she doesn't
waste it oh no she's out dang it is he smiling
no oh see I knew she'd at least have one got it
girl oh that guy save it for the mother Daddy's
got to die he called himself Daddy and you're not
Purge Daddy no so you got to go hunt him down and
kill them all save that Mexican son of a [__]
for me Purge and purify who that mask yeah that is
creepy wow how did they all get away yeah
I'm intrigued by that that they were able
to just run off she has one left who she can
use it for Daddy exactly well I mean they're
coming it's got to be one all right
he oh the Rope he's going to cattle
them Dam dam she going to sacrifice herself
for something no but I do think she has a plan
or like risky something she goes out there maybe
pretends that she's surrendering with then shoots
him they hot oh
cool
okay yes all we need is one now we have a
gun rest of you go stop crossing the border
it's just like being pregnant
is super not ideal in
this whoa wa that was a crazy shot did
he just hit that guy he just ran him
over what happened okay come on guys stick
a stick in the spoke yeah rope him off come
on oh
no oh God okay white gu got to save
you now up wake up wake up okay wake
up dynamite there's a gun just
there I guess I was hoping she
would like oh he kicks it away now
she picked it up oh don't miss she's
blurry if she shoots her husband that
will be the saddest thing ever suck
oh no she got taken shoot oh oh
by Daddy this dude this dude is
such a all right now we got to rope him and
awesome okay somebody use the horns I'm
glad a
this man is a g nice call your people and tell
them you need help I want to see some cowboy
stuff though oh well yeah you got to save it for
Daddy right be like call your people ask them for
help what are you Su somebody did
a thing that I support take those
weapons I'll do it speak English I will
cut your throat yes finally rope them
oh oh be careful with that gun there
yeah definitely shoot him I mean for
sure oh all [Music]
right again I love them so there are good
guys and there are bad guys and that guy
that they just killed was a really really
bad guy didn't matter that he was a white
dude he was a bad dude yeah and that's what
this guy on the right Sky will learn yeah
what's blonde coover Cowboy name I don't
know this costum in the ankle she'll be
there I don't support that I hate
that why we don't know that it's
like totally safe I really don't like that
oh my God she delivered the baby oh wow look who's
here thank
congratulations fake baby is
not moving at all at all such a
doll oh I knew they'd kiss of the nffa
has sent the military into every major
city and county the nffa is being destroyed
by their own creation yeah yeah that's what
I said all of the United States as we
once knew it may be disappearing who
knows what will the new America look
like when this all ends looks all yeah
like yeah okay music though where was music yeah
we didn't have uh good music drops in this like
we did in the last ones thank you to Shopify
for sponsoring which is what we use for our
merch store and is our gamechanging partner in
e-commerce so whether you're launching a passion
project or scaling to new heights Shopify is
e-commerce Powerhouse guiding you at every
step from creating your first online store to
opening physical locations Shopify makes it
seamless it's perfect whether you're selling
exclusive merch or unique Collectibles thanks
to their all-encompassing platform for both online
and in store sales their checkout system unmatched
it's 36% more effective at converting visitors
into buyers than other platforms and let's not
forget Shopify magic the AI tool that elevates
your business with minimal effort but seriously
reflecting on your journey using Shopify for
www. reation shop.com it's been transformative
the transition smooth growth exponential thank
you again reject Nation from simplifying sales
to scaling our offerings Shopify has been a
Cornerstone of our success and Shopify isn't
just for us it Powers 10% of us e-commerce backing
businesses big and small in over 175 countries
their awardwinning support always there to guide
you so ready to join the revolution sign up for
Shopify at only a dollar a month at shopify.com
Regen all lowercase shopify.com rejects start your
Shopify success story now let's grow together
with Shopify team big thanks to expressvpn
for sponsoring this video a real game changer
I've been using for years that's right years
so whenever they want to work with us it's an
instant yes you've likely heard about expressvpn
for online privacy and security but there's
more to it than that however there was a very
real incident recently with Spectrum showing down
my internet and contacting me due to a suspecting
hacking attempt and funny enough I realized I
hadn't actually activated my expressvpn on my
new laptop that I got a couple of months ago so I
was paying the consequences having faced a serious
hacking issue on YouTube a couple years ago that
made expressvpn my go-to for both security and
freedom I mean it and yes what you've heard is
true believe me this channel knows you can use
expressvpn to watch movies and shows on Netflix
that are not available in your country this means
accessing a vast rate of content of over a 100
countries like a global Cinema your fingertips
it's super easy open expressvpn switch locations
refresh the browser and there you have it whether
it's kramas on South Korean Netflix hul BL BBC I
player YouTube or more expressvpn has you covered
and it's incredibly fast ensuring no buffering or
lack for smooth HD streaming it's versatile too
working on not just computers but phones media
consoles Smart TVs and more this means you can
enjoy your favorite shows on anywhere any screen
protect and elevate your internet experience so
if you want to get access to hundreds of new shows
use my link expressvpn.com Rejects and you can get
an extra 3 months of expressvpn for free that's
expressvpn.com rejects so head expressvpn.com reex
to learn more thank you again let's see for once
and for all was his name Bill Patton that's what
I'm going to go with let's see all right okay we
got to I got to check it out while I'm checking it
out you tell me how did the forever Purge stack
up that was our fifth Purge I actually really
liked it I think I liked it well uh the last one
right we said we you that we didn't love it and
you guys know even I forgot Purge Daddy and I
was you know my brain but that was in the last
one nope it was in the second but I'm just saying
sometimes it takes a second for my brain to catch
up Will Patton Will Patton so I said first I said
will I think I started with Will and then I turned
to Bill y bill is a nickname for William though
right yes okay so I was right the whole you're
close you're close she did it she found it um uh
Armageddon yeah yeah okay and then we got to oh
and he's oh he's amazing in silo okay great great
and this other guy is Josh Lucas and Josh Lu JH
Lucas IED callab oh and he's in Yellowstone also
yeah okay so there's just a lot going on there's
a lot going on Purge Mommy okay so last one we
didn't love this one I like definitely better
yeah me too I didn't love I didn't love like some
of the exposition that they gave like the pregnant
woman and some of the stuff that was going on
where um thumb is that okay I think it is because
that's the backup this thing is you guys at home
us non Tech Geniuses we're Frozen let's just hope
they're not frozen for you guys okay keep going I
didn't love the exposition where like especially
when the pregnant woman's like we got to get
out of here and then also uh uh white dude who's
married to her like when they're in the van he's
like we got to get you to Mexico stuff like that
bugs me cuz we already know we're going to Mexico
and this other girl could feed information while
she's getting through this creepy room with Adella
protecting her that part but there wasn't a ton of
exposition in it I really liked it I liked um
them the The Flipper roon where obviously the
people that he does not like uh have to now save
him uh and I liked at the end where it's there
it's obviously going to form a nice relationship
the entire premise of this I thought was good it
they did a good job of flipping it on its head
where it's just like you are sitting so pretty
here in America looking at people who are crossing
the border and looking down on them like why did
they do this they're coming to our country right
and now when you need their help they're welcoming
you open arms trying to get you there and it makes
you stop and think about your prejudices that you
have against people I thought they did a good
job with that with that one character because
they don't make him an evil prick they make him
ignorant and they I'm talking about coover guy
they make him ignorant and they make him unlikable
but his he's like not going around throwing slurs
you know he doesn't have a swastika on his
face like we just know okay this guy has a
lot of growing up to do like he's just not he's
not a great dude but then people can change and
through this through kindness and love we do see
him start to change and I like that messaging I I
think that I love any movie that tries to unite
instead of divide and any movie that's like one
love and I think that nationalism as a thing is
kind of wild that we've created these borders
these separations these divisions between people
between countries obviously I'm speaking from an
idealistic perspective right now but like we're
all human beings that's the most important race
is the human race um and in this movie I feel
like they really tried to tackle that issue
and show like just because you were born here
doesn't make your life more valuable and you
can't just close your mind to the fact that you
might love somebody of a different country or a
different race or different religion you might
need somebody of a different background than you
you might Thrive with somebody of you know like so
of all of those things I feel like because of that
while this wasn't my favorite of The Purge movies
I think that the first uh couple strong yeah one
two and three I I really like but the reason I
did like this more than four is I really really
feel like I got what they were going for and they
did execute that now was there a lot of exposition
dialogue for sure uh did this have purge's daddy
going on no it did not in the same way but we did
have Purge Mommy we got Purge mommy and I really
like that I did like that they made the two women
in this like strong where it was like the sister's
like I'll protect you and she knows how to use a
gun and so does Adella the pregnant wife doesn't
didn't do too much but the other two women did and
they came through and I like that but I like your
suggestion was with the sister-in-law it did feel
a little bit like I would have loved to have seen
her have they gave us some glimpses that she's
into this one other dude and that's maybe why
she's helping uh the Mexican people but she for
the most part when she's like no I'm going to stay
and fight and were kind of like what like we would
seen that from you I would have loved to have seen
scenes of them in the barn talking or like scenes
of them where we understand that she is not her
brother-in-law we do get that moment on the table
right so we know that she doesn't have the same
beliefs as him with I got to introduce you to
this person or whatever but in general I just I
thought this was a really really solid franchise
and I think that this did something really cool by
not staying on Purge Night yeah that was awesome
that you're like oh yeah what we have said since
the beginning of like this is eventually going to
bite them in the ass right because why are people
actually following the rules that when the alarm
goes off and the sun comes up that everybody
just stops second and I'm like yeah would that
actually happen I like that they explored that
it it may not people would get hip to it and go
let's continue it and on top of that what are the
ramifications what are the repercussions of the
Society of what they've built and we haven't been
able to see that one time you know the most that
we have seen from any Purge movie after The Purge
is five minutes it's and it's always happy it's
just them reuniting being like a lie making it to
the hospital or you know not killing somebody and
then making it to the hospital like being having
the moral High Ground whatever it is we get those
five minutes and we see hope and future and like
okay to the next year but this actually showed
us for the first time like this is [__] this
is not helpful and this is caused more division
than unity and something also that I thought
was interesting was how you and I were kind of
confused on what people's positions were because
this isn't quite our world and it is a little
confusing because the government has set these
rules right yeah but then at the end of the day
the government is sending the military to try to
rescue people but those are the same people that
are doing this because of the choices that the
government has made so at that point those are
anti-government people but through all the other
Purge movies the anti-government people have been
the good guys but in this The anti- Purge for one
night people were the bad guys so the people who
were raging against the government in this were
the bad guys as opposed to every other Purge movie
where it it was the good guys raging against the
government right right mean because they're like
we don't like The Purge and we don't support it
but now yes now this one definitely flipped it
because it just became a a forever thing and you
can't really you can't really justify like who's
who like when they were running away trying to
get to the Border we like now they are absolutely
[__] because you have no idea who is a purger
and who is just escaping because everyone escaping
and a purger is going to have a weapon and try to
defend themselves at this point it's pure chaos
and the world is on fire which is why that flag
saved them um I mean at this point I'd be like I
wish there was a Hobby Lobby I got a spray paint
Purge purification on me yeah but then you might
get killed by somebody who I know who's like who's
like screw you but then I yeah I mean it's it's
complicated yeah that's what I did like about
this this was more nuan there weren't two types
of people there were a bunch of different types of
people people who had previously been probably Pro
Purge I mean we did see that the wife the pregnant
wife was not pro Purge which was interesting
because I had said Texas is probably Pro Purge but
then we see the pregnant wife who's like [__]
The Purge this sucks you know like don't let the
nffa tell us what to do yeah and it's like oh okay
so in our world is that a liberal person right I
assume so but then she's the rich girl who is who
is part of that perpetrating the system with
the farming system so is this a conservative
so it was kind of cool to see the Nuance of like
not everybody under different umbrellas has all
the same values you know and we you're seeing
that in our current world today where like you
might identify as one thing but you it there's a
it doesn't mean that you have gray area yeah like
the over all arch of one specific point of view
doesn't mean it's everything that you believe in
exactly and then in this when we're watching I'm
like I think I know what that person's about and
then they make different decisions like with the
uh white blonde Cowboy guy when we were like oh
screw this guy and I was like he's not going
to make it to the end he's not going to live
because he's a douche and then it's like oh oh
he actually is ignorant and he is adapting and
learning and growing and we do need to allow for
people to do that so while he's not as good of
a guy as um our two lead Mexican people the Juan
and um uh alah Al Adel Adela Adel a d e l i feel
you made a little sheep her ad what they called
her as like those are clearly our protagonists
right those are our Good Guys in this and he's
not that but he's also not uh not mother mother
and father daddy mother weird guy yeah I think I
would have liked at the end because we still got
Exposition from other people that if you're going
to have that there at least have maybe him at the
end just go hey thank you like a genuine thank you
to go like he we've seen him go with it them it's
probably made a change it's not really confirmed I
don't know but I do think if we don't want him to
be uh to still have that like bad juice inside of
him going through all that I would have liked to
see him like thank them did he do that did he say
thank you and I just like BL on earlier on he did
when he like kep the car but no I would have liked
the moment again at the end just a a moment of
like yeah and then the other people don't say any
like thank you back it's just it's a head nod and
it get get out and we understand each other more
now I know that this isn't part of the review as
much but like what happens from here yeah I mean
it's it's refugees in Mexico yeah it's the flip of
now we have way more American refugees than we've
it's mostly always other countries and now it's
it's America's like burnt to the ground and you
know what's so funny is that a lot of my Mexican
friends give me [__] when I say Americans
because that's not what they call us because I
guess like it's all it when we're North America am
your North America like to them that is part of an
America so it's like the I guess the United States
people are or refugees yes they like the same
continent yeah because it's in yeah I get what
you're saying just like they're probably coming
like America and they're like yeah we're part of
that too we're all North America bro yeah yeah
we're all included you're the ones who put up this
[__] wallart border you freaks yeah uh I would
like a forever Purge sequel to see what was going
on with the Canada Border yeah that would have
been that would have it would be cool to see also
to see like them having to live without status I
mean now the white people who are in Mexico their
status and their money and their houses and their
cars and their gold is gone so their whole way of
living is going to be new and I'd be so interested
of like you're now sleeping in a tent not not
that I mean she had her baby she had an IV like
they had it set up it's not like they're gonna
have you're not going home to a house yeah no
I would like to see how they're going to live
their life but then yeah also how how did The
Purge happen in Canada I don't know so this movie
was in 2021 to me that me that was so recent very
recent that means to me that there's not like a
door closed on The Purge franchise I genuinely
think that there's more stories to be told here
about post Purge putting it back together going
back to earlier purges like there's just I this
premise is good not one of these movies has been
a waste of time no no no they've all been great
and they they always make us think on like a
a moral ground like an idea of like what's the
moral ground here what's like right and what's
wrong and why do people live this way like it it
evokes a lot of thought all right I think we did
it we did it we purged The Purge we did it did we
forever Purge though I I hope not because I would
like to see some more but how' you feel about
the spider situation I didn't see any single
one I mean I believe that they were maybe in the
foreground maybe just too small for us to see it
I think we got rid of them I think we purged them
yeah okay okay thanks for being here with us guys
uh if there's another Purge we'll be back here for
that otherwise leave suggestions if you want to
see us cover a different franchise or a different
thing we'll be back here anyway we will uh and and
perator it's a weird sign off I that was good I
don't think pilat works P perator yeah they get
it all right John pick your name Andrew Hayes
Andrew Hayes you know what I'm going to get you
for Christmas this year know Santa's delivering
to you oh coming down that JY he is delivering
first an operating table he hey you're going to
wake up strapped to an operating table it's going
to be there you're going to think you're in some
weird Nightmare and you're in some sleep paralysis
thing that you just cannot get out of like I
need to wake up but ho ho ho no no you're on
the naughty list you're on the naughty list this
year as Santa is going to uh surgically remove
your legs without anesthesia because anesthesia
is a sin for some reason yeah and he's Christian
Scientist he doesn't believe in medication and
he's going to make sure your mouth is just really
taped shut so that would you can't even scream
man you can't even do it but he's going to give
you a new pair of leg so you're taller but dude
you're going to be like what are those mythical
creatures with the Hooves the oh like uh like Mr
tness kind what is a Mr tness uh he's got like
goat legs goat legs on yeah those guys fawn fwn
yeah he's a f he's turning you into a fawn and
Santa's going to turn you into a fawn you're going
to you're wake you're be taller be like whoa I can
see above the table and I can like run super I run
and then you take off your jeans to see your new
big thing and you're going to be like oh my God
Santa gave me Fawn legs yeah and you're going to
be like oh no and that's the ironic tale is you
are now taller but you have Fawn legs yeah so
at what cost did you achieve this height for and
and the ultimate mystery that we cut away from to
commercial break is like did he leave your thing
or did he give you a fond thing and which one is
bigger you know well that's what the sequels
for oh that's right yeah it's Andrew trying
to find love his own kind so Andrew I hope this
holiday season you could learn to adjust to your
new life you could have been just a paraplegic
you could have but now you got Fawn legs so i'
say you should have been ver uh so really man you
should have been a paraplegic man you should have
just said no Santa no please just no I don't need
the PA leg keep my keep my stumps uh but really
man it's your call and I hope you have a great
Christmas with your family and your hot mom and
uh continue saving people from getting their
houses broken in yes my fawn man [Music] yeah